liz's math test included a survey
question asking how many hours students
spent studying for the test
the scatter plot and trend line below
show the relationship between how many
hours students spent studying and their
score on the test
the line fitted to the model the line
fitted to model the data has a slope of
15.
so the
line they're talking about is right here
so this is a scatter plot this shows
that some student who spent some time
between half an hour and an hour
studying and got a little bit less than
a 45 on the test the student here who
got a little bit higher than a 60 spent
a little under two hours studying this
student over here who looks like they
got like a 94 or 95 spent over four
hours studying and so then they fit a
line to it and this line has a slope of
15. and before i even read these choices
what's the best interpretation of the
slope
well if you think this line is
indicative of the trend and it does look
like that from the scatter plot that
implies that roughly every extra hour
that you study is going to improve your
score by 15. you could say on average
according to this regression so
if we start over here and we were to
increase by one hour our score should
improve by 15. and it does indeed look
like that we're going from
we're going in the horizontal direction
we're going one hour and then the
vertical direction we're going from 45
to 60. so that's how i would interpret
it every hour
based on this regression you could it's
not unreasonable to expect 15 points
improvement or at least that's what
we're seeing
that's what we're seeing from the
regression of the data so let's look at
which of these choices actually describe
something like that
the model predicts that the student who
scored 0 studied for an average of 15
hours
no it definitely doesn't say that
the model predicts that students who
didn't study at all will have an average
score 15 points no we didn't we didn't
see that students if you if you take
this if you believe this model someone
who doesn't study at all would get close
to would get between 35 and 40 points so
like a 37 or 38. so don't like that
choice
the model predicts that the score will
increase 15 points for each additional
hour of study time yes that is exactly
what we were thinking about when we were
looking at the model that's what a slope
of 15 tells you you increase
studying time by an hour it increases
score by 15 points
the model predicts that the study time
will increase 15 hours for each
additional point scored well no and
first of all
hours is the thing that we've used the
independent variable and the points
being the dependent variable and this is
phrasing it the other way and you
definitely wouldn't expect to do an
extra 15 hours for each point